l'engouement pour les protéines
végétales ne se dément pas et dans les
prairies cet engouement il se mesure au
nombre d'hectares de légumineuses et
aussi au nombre d' usine de
transformation construites ou en voie de
l'être tour d'horizon de la culture du
pois jaunes une petite légumineuses dont
les superficies ont fait des bonds de
gier
[Musique]
printemps 2020 les semis battent leur
plein dans la région de la montagne un
escarpement qui surplombe les grandes
plaines du manitoba
luc charrière et son fils daniel cultive
des céréales à la ferme familiale mais
l'hectare sur tous mes en blé et en
canola
[Musique]
mais cette année les cherrière consacre
85 hectares à une culture de rotation
qui n'ont jamais semé le pois jaunes nos
terrains un peu plus légers puis on
pense que les porcs sont un meilleur
foot pour notre type de terrain ici
les chars hier ont déjà un acheteur un
transformateur de protéines végétales
qui leur offre une prime de 50 cents le
boisseau au delà de la valeur marchande
une bonne récolte entraînerait un revenu
additionnel de 8000 dollars
ok les plumes sa
satire au monde alors qu'amy rigarda
forme
la récolte des charrières à bout de six
rames à l' usine de transformation de la
multinationale roquettes à portage la
prairie ici en construction à l'hiver
une usine de 600 millions de dollars
consacré entièrement à une seule petite
légumineuses le pois jaunes
la protéine qui est extraite du poids à
une très bonne composition c'est à dire
qu'elle est facilement assimilable par
par l'être humain donc d'un point de vue
nutrition c'est une très bonne protéines
ensuite le poids est et non ogm ce qui
est quand même important
dominique pourre man dirige cette usine
de transformation de poids la plus
importante au monde un édifice imposant
que l'on voit à des dizaines de
kilomètres symbole tangible du pari que
fait roquettes quant au potentiel de la
protéine végétale
c'est un marché en plein développement
c'est presque une révolution le canada
est le premier producteur de poids au
monde donc être prêt de la matière
première est extrêmement importante pour
nous
[Musique]
luc labossière était l'un des premiers à
cultiver du poids à grande échelle ici
dans les années 80 s'est
lancé à la france
puis il ya eu un intérêt qui s'est
développé dans la région mais la récolte
est capricieuse et les prix étaient
volatiles à l'époque les premiers année
sa pole nécessairement tout le plaisir
des machines grand quel salaire sans
nalla fall à qatar et
le port amos le méditer aussi vite
qu'elle loge ya du bon que son cas n'est
de trop puis la une a pas beaucoup qui
ont resté dedans
dans les années 90 le prix des
légumineuses monte en flèche surtout en
raison d'une forte demande des pays
asiatiques
la production de poids dans les prairies
passe de 500 mille tonnes en 1992 à plus
de 4 millions de tonnes en 2010 est
la quasi totalité de cette production
est exportée
pecquencourt souhaite changer cela
il est la figure de proue de protein and
street canada un nouvel organisme qui
vise à garder une plus grande partie de
nos récoltes au pays
nous avons développé une véritable
industrie de nettoyage d'emballage et de
polissage pour des marchés comme l'inde
et le bangladesh qui consomment la
légumineuse non transformé
mais depuis quelques années les
protéines végétales se taille une place
de plus en plus importante dans nos
assiettes ce qui n'est pas sans
bouleverser la production
agroalimentaire des prairies
la population augmente mais il ya aussi
que de plus en plus de consommateurs de
partout dans le monde se soucie de
l'impact qu'a leur alimentation sur
l'environnement
y milenio en particulier sont très
sensibles aux questions de bien-être
animal de santé et de développement
durable
selon une récente étude commanditée par
poutine industrie canada 43 % des
canadiens comptent augmenter leur
consommation de protéines végétales et
15% compte réduire leur consommation de
viande
les protéines végétales représente déjà
un marché de 500 millions de dollars par
année au pays un chiffre qui augmente à
vue d'oeil
intérêt grandissant pour les aliments
d'origine végétale et l'abondance des
matières premières ont été déterminants
pour la construction d'une usine de
transformation dans les prairies
en saskatchewan et au manitoba
un projet d' usine de transformation
n'attend pas l'autre
sonia kanu la lentille chanvre féveroles
des cultures qui ont la cote dans cette
véritable ruée vers l'isola de protéines
végétales
le plus ambitieux projet celui de la
multinationale roquettes alimentera
entre autres le marché de substituts de
viande à pleine capacité 125 mille
tonnes de poids seront transformés ici
chaque année
le produit final c'est un concentré une
poudre protéine est destiné à la
production de toutes sortes d'aliments
on mesure la granulométrie de la poudre
c'est en fait en train une barre de
céréales et puis un biscuit le client
n'a pas les mêmes besoins alors que les
transformateurs poursuivre leur travail
pour adapter les protéines végétales à
notre palais
les chants des prairies vivent eux aussi
une transformation palpable
si les champs de l'udc cherrière n'avait
pas été semées en poids à l'été 2020
c'est plutôt du soya qui pousserait ici
or les rendements de soya ne sont pas
toujours bons dans cette région des
prairies en général ici au moins doux
c'est la clé soyaux se remplit les
gosses remplir puis cela qu'en rendant
le problème ouzou
on manque d'eau mode où on voit comparé
au chant de poids ici à ma droite comme
à gauche la fef sur yon vos clés de en
fait les poissons beaucoup plus avancé
en termes de développement réjean picard
l agronome responsable de la région de
la montagne
lorsque luc charrière lui a signalé son
intention de semer des poids plutôt que
du soya il n'a pas hésité à l'appuyer
du terrain qui était vallonneux qui est
bien drainés ce qui est très très
convenable pour les poids et puis on est
quelques centaines de puits un peu plus
haut c'est plus frais les pros c'est une
culture qui profitent dans ces
conditions là comme le soya le poids est
aussi une excellente culture de rotation
qui permet aux fermiers de réduire leurs
dépenses en engrais chimiques
ce sont tous des bactéries qui sont
associés avec la racine de la plante
c'est ce qu'ils veulent qu'ils vont
contribuer à la fixation de la zone
dollar où il va être fournir la plante
après l'ontario le manitoba est le
deuxième producteur de soja au pays or
le nombre d'hectares semer en soya ici a
chuté de moitié entre 2017 et 2020
surtout en raison d'une baisse du prix
en revanche le pois jaunes a le vent
dans les voiles les hectares augmente de
10 % par année dans les prairies depuis
2000 16
sacres et l'intérêt dans la france
profite donc c'est pour ça qu'on a ça et
de rester dedans
quant à luc labossière notre vendeur de
semences il récolte aujourd'hui les
fruits de sa persévérance
il est l'un des plus importants vendeurs
de semences de pois jaunes au manitoba
et ses ventes augmentent de 25 % par
année depuis trois ans la compagnie
c omme chaque chose qu'on le paie ici
pour rester je pense louis
hausse de production de légumineuses
dans les champs secteur de la
transformation en plein essor flambée
des prix autant de signes encourageants
pour les provinces des prairies mais
selon bio goods c'est loin d'être
suffisant si le canada souhaite
réellement profiter de cette révolution
alimentaire
[Musique]
nous estimons transformer 550 mille
tonnes de légumineuses annuellement ça
peut sembler beaucoup mais au canada
uniquement dans le poids on produit
entre 5 et 6 millions de tonnes chaque
année le secteur de la transformation un
grand potentiel de croissance
en dépit des nouveaux transformateurs
85% de nos légumineuses sont toujours
exporter les secteurs public et privé
sont appelés à se mobiliser pour
augmenter rapidement la capacité de
transformation en sol canadien
évidemment nous ne sommes pas les seuls
à avoir mesuré le potentiel des aliments
à base de végétaux
il ya présentement une véritable course
mondiale pour établir des usines de
transformation
une fois construite six usines ne
bougeront plus de là alors on sent
l'urgence d'agir au canada
l'enjeu assurer notre part de marché
mondiale qui pourrait dépasser les 250
milliards de dollars d'ici 2035
chez roquette l'usm est à peine
opérationnel que déjà un projet
d'expansion se dessine à l'horizon
maintenant on est sur un terrain de 100
acres on en utilise 65 donc on a
largement la place pour doubler tripler
quadrupler l'usiné
[Musique]
l'avenir de la transformation du poids
jaune passera forcément par les chants
des fermiers comme luc charrière
on a une belle cote une bonne cote on
est vraiment satisfait
encouragé par sa première récolte il
compte incorporer le pois jaunes à sa
rotation dans les années à venir et il
n'est pas seul tous les gars que j'ai
parlé avec sita satisfait à l'eau c'est
beaucoup une partie de la conversation
ils veulent en voir d'autres certains
[Musique]